yo what's up everybody we're back here
on chest coms YouTube channel this is
international master Daniel wrench and
today we're going to go over another
mainline tournament opening that you
need to know and what I'd like to do
today is continue with our coverage of
the mainline Open Sicilians as you can
see here we've set up the position once
again after whites to 9 of 3 preparing
to enter the open Sicilian and as you
can see from the title of this video we
are here to learn the sveshnikov
sicilian the sveshnikov is one of the
most dynamic and popular Sicilians
especially over the last decade we'll
even say over the last two decades it's
an opening that's designed around
achieving a very quick initiative a bind
on the queenside and dynamic counter
play to compensate for black positional
weaknesses the sveshnikov always starts
out with the move to Knight to c6 and
once again we're going to flip the board
around so that you can see this opening
from blacks perspective especially from
the beginning here as we talk about the
purpose and the idea behind black
playing the special coffee after white
plays d4 and we have C takes d4 Knight
takes d4 Knight f6 it should be noted
that here white cannot capture on c6 and
play e5 this early as black simply has
this move Queen a5 check forking the
King and pawn and winning material very
quickly however as you saw on the dragon
or accelerated dragon video after Knight
to c3 if black were to play this move
order and then try to go back into a
dragon that would no longer be possible
as now capturing an e5 would punish this
move order and once again force the
knight to a bad square or to sacrifice a
pawn
again that information was covered and
our dragon and accelerate dragon video
lecture you can check that out here in
our chess openings playlist but after 90
c3 the idea behind the special table is
a surprising move an aggressive move in
a very double-edged move something that
as a chess coach I do not teach my
students too early on in their career
that is to move e5 c5 is a move that
obviously immediately gains a tempo on
the knight and in doing so after the
main line you're going to see
black establishes a quickly development
like I said an initiative or a bind on
the queenside and long term dynamic
counterplay
however the weakness behind the movie
five is clear black has significantly
weakened the light squares in the center
particularly the d5 square as white has
an open file and access to the square
already and after natural play you'll
see that white is only able to increase
his control over these squares so why
would black do this
well after E 5 9 to be 5 and D 6 the
move Bishop to g5 is played in the
mainline a6 is played white has no other
choice but to retreat the night day 3
and after b5 we see the black has
actually made more moves per se than
white has as white ended up wasting
significant time with this night and now
must most time even a little bit further
as the threat of b4 is coming
forking the ponies on the queenside the
point is that black has established
early counter play with this minority
attack on the queenside as he would like
to do in every Sicilian but in the
special coffee does it as fast as any
other variation of the Sicilian probably
including the knight Orff and in doing
so he has established that he will get
good counter playing an initiative on
the Queen's up for the rest of the game
but coming back to the center what black
has done here is created an outpost
square on d5 for whites knight and as
there is always associated with an
outpost Square there was also a backward
pawn on d6 a backward pawn being one
that is left behind by his buddies and
is therefore weak on any open file so
White's two main advantages here in
compensation for the lost time with the
Knights and blacks binding on the Queen
side is access and control over the d5
square and potential to target this d6
pawn as we flip the board again to look
at White's perspective White has two
main moves here and on move 9 is where
we see the big difference in terms of
White's approach philosophically against
the sveshnikov one idea is to put the
knight on d5 immediately this move is
obviously strong as it prevents the
threat of b4 forking the two Knights
puts a piece on a very strong square and
intends to increase control of the light
squares for the rest of the game either
with moves like c4 trying to attack the
pawns and bring
the knight or Bishop to the square in
some cases even the plan of C 3 followed
by using this square for this for the
knight on a 3 and therefore relocating
it to a square that also increases
control on the light squares whether the
night ends up on III or B 4 and the move
Knight to d5 also obviously exerts
pressure in the black camp after this
move black and play Bishop d7 and after
Bishop takes Bishop takes as the threat
on Bishop e7 was to capture on d5 as the
move Bishop e7 unpinned the knight on f6
white trades it off and black and
compensation for this week knight on d4
this week square on d5 and therefore
outpost by the White Knight has counter
play on the Queen side already
established and potentially the
advantage of the bishop pair you'll
often see black Castle remove this
Bishop from f6 and try to play for f5
attacking in one direction of the board
the second line for white is to play the
move Bishop takes f6 immediately this
move as strong as black does not really
have the option to capture with the
Queen as after 95 gaining a tempo and
threatening Knight to c7 the move Queen
to d8 is played white can immediately
strike in the center with c4 and
continue with play on the Queen side and
the time the black has lost with the
Queen allowing this knight to come to d5
with tempo is rather significant so
instead black must capture with the pawn
on f6 and this scenario white will again
follow with Knight to d5 to avoid the
avoid the fork of the Knights on a3 and
C 3 and here black has further
weaknesses in addition to the d5 square
in the d6 pawn he now has double deaf
pawns however as we said black in this
special cough often has dynamic counter
play for the rest of the game black has
the potential open G file the two
bishops which in open positions can be a
dynamic advantage and the early threat
of f5 as you saw in the other variation
when white played Knight to d5 and
Bishop e7 though black did not have the
double pawns it was going to take some
time for him to remove this Bishop to
one square in order to get real counter
play whereas in this position after
Bishop takes and G takes despite the
fact that blacks position is certainly
not a pretty picture in terms of pawn
structure
squares black is immediately threatening
to put pressure on the center and will
often do so as early as this move here
10 f5 being one of the main lines in
this Vesna cough again in summary the
movie 5 is a risk and that in weakens
black center creating positionally
long-term problems on the light squares
however by gaining tempos on the night
and eventually expanding quickly on the
queenside black achieves dynamic
compensation in the form of counter play
on the queenside quick initiative and
eventual compensation of things such as
the bishop pair and play on the kingside
with a break of a5 one thing we'd like
to know quickly is that in the night
orphe 1 an opening that was already
covered here and our chess openings
playlist black will also try for this
ePHI structure you might even call it a
night or flash session of cops truck
sure even though it's not the special
cough opening however the reason why
black does not typically play this move
immediately and only does so after a six
in the night or is because e 5 would
once again significantly weaken the
light squares and in this case y would
have the intermezzo the in-between move
option to give check and trade off
blacks LightSquared bishop thus
increasing white's pressure potentially
on the light squares here even a retreat
of the night to a more passive square
like f3 or b 3 would be good enough for
white to maintain an advantage as these
light scores are significantly weak for
the rest of the game and black does not
have the early counter play coming on
that note we flip back to this vesnik
off and recognize the fact that when
black plays a 5 early here white must
play the move Knight to b5 in order to
put pressure on d6 as a passive retreat
in this position that was possible in
the knight Orff no longer works here
because blacks accelerated development
would allow a pin on the 9th immediately
threatening to take the e4 pawn and when
you follow that with threats such as d5
once again taking advantage of blacks
quick development to increase pressure
on the center we like blacks chances one
of the reasons why in fact the main
reason why white must play Knight d2 b5
right a way to put pressure on this
square preventing moves such as
developments with the
bishop because of the check thank you
for watching this video lecture on the
sveshnikov hope you're enjoying our
youtube channel having a little party
town in your head about all these free
opening lectures you're getting so you
stay in party town and you stay classy
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm